All right, bring it on!
Jackpot!
Why is it always me?
One backhand...
One...
C'mon Emil!
The worst serving ever!
It's impossible to play like this!
Ready?
Otto!
It was your turn!
It touched
Roller!
My mic...
My mic is dropping!
Catch it!
We are going to try to break this
With a table tennis smash
We found out a new instrument!
Give me a demonstration scream
Emil catch!
Oh! I actually got it!
Okay
I think you have got the touch now
Yeah
That was pathetic
Don't...
So guys leave a comment
on where you wanna come
make a new street battle willy
Street battle Willy!
Where did that come from?
Cut!
Maybe I start using this serve
Or maybe not...
Serve it with topspin...
prefe...
preferereralrlrr...
...rably
Like that
Prefererearlrlrably!
Creative video shooting
And today we will be playing
with musical instruments
Let's go!
Didn't see you there
Watch this!
Not-so-friendly pass
I should have catch that, I'm sorry
That was good!
I can't believe you got them back!
Okay so I have shaved my head off
Head off?
No, I haven't!
What happened there?
Do we have any rules?
The first rule: There is no rules!
Okay!
Nice match guys!
He went for it
Three all!
This is...
This is why you have rules in table tennis!
Let's go!
Actually it stayed there!
Good one!
What was that?
Five in a row!
Well, no more.
Thank you!
Hello Pongfinity (in German)
No...
Hello, hello!
Lederhosen!
Jawohl!
That was interesting!
It didn't do the chain reaction we were hoping...
Oh! Four!
1, 2, 3, 4!
Best so far!
What's up everybody!
What are you doing?
C'mon Miikka, focus!
No! It came out!
I have been doing this for like...
15 minutes now
I know what I'm doing!
Hope so!
Or no...
That was really close
That a stylish jump though!
What's up guys
We are Pongfinity
We have kids...
What?
We have kids!
And then the video ends there...
Thanks for the information!
And that's all for today!
Thanks for watching!
Don't show this to them
There?
No!
My hair has to go...
Under the hair
No!
The video where it kind of...
begin... began... begun
Begin, began, begun!
Pick out the right one
Yeah!
Okay so let's try 5 around the nets
with the edge of the table
With the racket...
Okay so let's try 5 around the nedge...
I give up
And watch our previous videos there
Until next time!
It sounds like a song actually
Miikka even looks like he knows what he is doing!
Where did that come from?
I have no idea
Always carrying a table tennis ball
Yeah
How many balls do you have!?
Unlimited balls!
They just keep dropping!
I have been working on my new serve
Come on
Come on!
How does the Enzo Angles serve go?
He serves somehow like that
Well, at least not like that...
What's up every...
I wasn't supposed to start...
It's time for the intro
And I went for the...
No! It's time for the outro...
It's time for the outro and I went for the intro
He is so messed up
Of course Emil!
Always so helpful!
There you go, Emil!
Next time it's time for you to do it yourself
So you start learning how to do it
Plus
Where did that come from?
Just hit it!
Let's try these out!
Let's see if anybody notices in the video...
That's funny
Keep it there
Is it visible?
It's not so visible
If you don't pay attention you might not even see it
I like the sound
Let's try these out!
So is it good now?
Yeah, now it's really good!
It's actually pretty good now
Maybe I should always have it...
But it hurts... it hurts a lot!
It makes it hard to speak
Put it in your teeth
Amazing thanks for...
helping us reach 100 million
100 million?
Well, you are a bit too early for that!
Just one year too early for that!